hello this is presh talwalkar
here are five facts that everyone should
know about the mathematical constant pi
fact number one the definition
pi is the ratio of the circumference of
a circle
to its diameter
that is pi equals the circumference
divided by the diameter
what's special is this is true for every
single circle whether the circle is very
big
or whether the circle is very small
pi will always be the ratio of the
circumference
to the diameter for every single circle
fact number two
pi is irrational
pi is equal to approximately 3.1415
and so on
the decimal form continues on forever
and it never repeats
the fraction 22 over 7
is accurate to 2 decimal places and the
fraction 355 over 113 is accurate to six
decimal places
but because pi is a rational
there is no fraction a over b where a
and b are integers that will be exactly
equal to pi
pi is also transcendental
which means pi will never be the root or
the solution of a non-constant
polynomial with integer coefficients
fact number three
archimedes estimated pi more than two
thousand years ago
archimedes considered a circle which had
a diameter of one
the circumference of this circle
will be equal to pi
so archimedes thought
he could estimate the circumference of
the circle
by considering drawing a hexagon inside
of the circle
the perimeter of this hexagon will be
clearly less than the circumference of
the circle which is pi
archimedes also consider drawing a
hexagon around the circle
now the perimeter of this hexagon will
be larger than the circumference of the
circle
so we can have an upper bound for pi
using trigonometry archimedes could
calculate the perimeter of the hexagon
and estimate pi
he then ingeniously doubled the number
of sides and considered the same
argument for a 12 gun
he doubled the number of sides again and
considered the argument for a 24 gone
he could calculate these perimeters of
the inscribed and circumscribed
perimeters to get
and lower bound and upper bound for pi
he got all the way to the 96 god in
which he found that pi must be wedged
between 223 over 71 and 22 over 7.
this gave him an approximation that pi
is about 3.14
which was very good and often practical
fact number four pi can be expressed in
many infinite series
this is my favorite infinite series pi
over four equals one minus one-third
plus one-fifth minus one-seventh plus
one-ninth and so on as the alternating
sum
of odd fractions
this is the leibniz formula which was
also discovered by the indian
mathematician madhava
another formula is pi squared over six
is equal to one over one squared plus
one over two squared plus one over three
squared and so on
this formula was found by euler
and it's a beautiful relationship
between the numbers and pi
there are also many complicated infinite
series this is one similar to one the
indian mathematician ramanujan would
have come up with and these types of
formulas are used in the shidnovsky
algorithm which is how pi is determined
algorithmically on computers
fact five
pi comes up in probability
here's a drawing of the normal curve or
the bell curve which you've seen in
statistics class to describe many
different
data
the equation of the curve is e to the
power of minus one half x squared
divided by the square root of 2 pi
so even in probability pi is a very
important constant and it comes up
consider buffon's needle problem
imagine randomly dropping a needle of
length l
on a floor where the lines are one unit
apart
what's the probability the needle will
intersect with one of the lines
the answer is two times the length of
the needle divided by
pi so unexpectedly pi comes up even in
probability
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can get my
books listed on my website follow my
blog mind your decisions
follow my decisions on facebook on
google plus
catch me on preshtalwalker on twitter
instagram and tumblr
and you can support me on patreon